I'd like to ask you or what is God to
you who are what is God to make yes and
what role if any does that that's my man
I mean is you know it's the creator of
the universe master of heaven earth
who's got to me God is as an Orthodox
Jew I believe that God provided us a
moral foundation in the Bible and that
that moral foundation is if you live by
that moral foundation you will live a
happier better life freer of sin you
know I think that God provides the idea
of an objective moral standard that
immediately begins to crumble as soon as
you get to a subjective idea that
everybody can create their own morality
so that's the best I think the role of
God in society you know as far as what
has God to me personally you know all I
can say is that I don't believe in God I
know when God you know I don't just have
faith in God I have trust in God and so
that may not end up well for me because
it doesn't always end up well for people
to take but you know I think that that
you know not recognizing God's
providence over the universe from me
particularly would be an act of
tremendous ingratitude